welcome back to Facebook organization
this show is nothing if not a Fearless
forum for fiery debate I have strong
opinions but like all the world's
eminent thinkers I'm open to changing my
mind so tonight I'm trying something a
little new
prove me wrong it's the title of his new
segment first up is the royal family
worth the money the annual Crown report
into Royal finances was released today
King Charles and Co appear to have maxed
out the Royal credit card last year they
spent 107 million pounds while The
Sovereign Grant was only 86.3 million
pounds that means we're in the hole for
around 20.7 million pounds extra big
numbers indisputably but in my view the
royal family still represents stunningly
good value I say they're worth every
penny here to debate the complete
opposite Alex O'Connor the YouTuber and
we're all skeptic and Graham Smith chief
executive of the UK's leading Republican
movement Republic who's just handed me
his new book abolish the monarchy why we
should and how we will so clear we're on
different uh we're on different paths
here but the rules are simple you guys
have until you hear this sound
to prove me wrong I say the Royals are
worth every penny that this country
gives them which by the way is literally
really one penny per person in this
country a year
per day birthday not yes so it's a penny
a day per person in the country well
it's not and the point the first thing
to say about this this debate is that
the monarchy is not a financial
transaction so whether it's got makes a
profit or not is neither here nor there
the measure of whether it's a good
institution and worth keeping is whether
it's good constitutionally because
that's what it's there for why are you
so against it and out of interest
because firstly the whole life is
devoted to ending the monarchy
personally it's wrong in principle it's
not Democratic it stands on completely
different set of feudal values instead
of the values of accountability equality
and Democratic rights and so on secondly
as an institution it is not fit for
purpose it falls well short of the
principles of public life
um I don't think it's going too far to
say it's corrupt and constitutionally in
terms of our politics and and the way
power is exercised it funnels a lot of
power what have been the four most
watched events globally involving this
country in the last three years yeah but
that doesn't really
oh yeah going to say the weddings and
the Jews answer my question you're going
to say the weddings in the jubilees I'm
not sure that's even the case because I
think UEFA had um well forget it forget
football okay you can't just say forget
football no it's National events
National events
universally so this country for the
coronation nine percent of this country
were enthusiastic about the coronation
15 by another poll so you know in terms
of royalists most people you know people
that you can genuinely call royalists is
less than 15 all right but see here's
the point I think which I think you both
you guys are missing but I mean try and
convince me Alex I just think when the
world looked at the Platinum Jubilee for
example when the world looked in a very
different tone at the Queen's funeral
the king's coronation you look at these
events and it shows Britain in my view
at its greatest the pomp the pageantry
the ceremony the military Precision
everything worked like clockwork
everyone around the world who was
watching this who was watching like it
was a caveat many people are not
interested at that but the millions tens
of millions around the world that
watched it thought better of our country
how many things has happened in our
country in the last three years
involving our leaders for example which
have brought shame and ignominy to the
country here you have a chance to show
us at our best what price do you put
there's nothing about the royal family
that's brought us shame in your opinion
that you've been sort of relentlessly
human beings
and you say you know it doesn't help us
to escape the various political scandals
of prime ministers and presidents well
it does it I I thought you were the one
who's constantly banging on about Harry
and Megan and how there are disgrace to
our country or whatever it is I don't
think well I think I think rather like
YouTube they're attempts to damage the
monarchy and bring it down are actually
disgraceful because I happen to support
the monarchy of an argument a few big
events is not an argument for a
Constitution which is second rate it's
not an argument for an institution that
abuses public money that abuses public
office to lobby for their interests and
so on I mean you know 12th was it 13
years ago 14 years ago now the MP's
expenses Scandal
um I'm sure you're one of the the many
commentators who are outraged by MP
spending public money on their own homes
their second homes yeah and that was
sort of hundreds of pounds thousands of
pounds sometimes tens of thousands of
pounds the Royals spent Millions tens of
millions but you know my view of that my
view of that our money if you're going
to if you're going to have a monarchy
and a royal family and they're
performing over a thousand duties a year
which is not a lot well they're actually
getting lots of charities
help for people right they couldn't do
his private citizens well they could
they wouldn't have the same impact okay
but here's my here's my point here's my
point if you're going to have them you
should give them all the trappings WoW
otherwise they're not a royal family but
like not a monarchy where's the logic is
if you want people to buy into the magic
of a monarchy and royal family you've
got to give them the tools but it should
be magic it's not magic it's corruption
what would you have them in a little
just Tesla I mean maybe a maybe a suit
that'd be fine we could start by getting
rid of these ridiculous garments we
spent most of the time that we've known
dressed like me and so to see him for
the first time you're on the king dress
like No Effects well he'd probably put
on a tie it looked more like you I
suppose yes to see and suddenly put on
these robes would be like watching Rishi
sunak or someone suddenly a lot of our
history
it gives us something it's so few other
countries
many around the world love it if you go
to the Caribbean if you go to America
you go to Canada you go to India you go
anywhere in the world Australia and they
bring you just so much money from
tourism well that's not true but it is
true
now the thing is there is no evidence
and I've sat down with the CEO and chair
visit Britain uh about a decade ago and
I said there's no evidence that if we
got rid of the monarchy tourism would go
down and they said yes you absolutely
you don't think the royal family brings
in any money no evidence that that
tourism money wouldn't come in anyway I
mean if you don't like this you just
just look at the money that came in in
the weeks leading up to these big events
that we've had about before you look at
these huge amounts of money if you look
at the visiting number American tourists
the visitors
let's go down when these things happen
if you look at the visitor numbers they
go down when these people stay away from
these kind of things and I may say
Cheshire zoo is a bigger tourist
attraction in the UK than Buckingham
Palace or Windsor Castle I wouldn't be
in favor of a state-funded ceremony
certainly what's the birth of a penguin
at Chester's I certainly would not be
but don't do they oh it's owners or it's
directors or indeed the the the sort of
sometimes Sinister and yet still to be
pitied animals that are kept within its
cages foreign
thing you've said on this show and that
says a lot the bar is low I agree to say
that this is something that requires
royalty say this is something that
requires he has some kind of political
office that he's going to inherit the
head of uh head of statehood that he's
going to become the head of state of
this country they've got anything to do
with his ability to get three million
pounds of Charities
you argue a case with great Passion but
in the end it's just a negative anti-art
no it's not that's what you are not at
all a pair of you wake up every day and
you think how do I end this thing I hate
why don't you just ignore it it's a bit
like you see what it is we're having a
vegan debate in a minute it's a bit like
vegans you run into steakhouses
screaming abuse
it's in a little restaurant in the
corner it's a bit like they need to eat
steak is actually a bit like getting up
in the morning saying I want to end
homelessness because I hate it I want to
end monetary because it is a bad thing
it's bad it's bad for our government not
bad it's bad for our governance
ceremony when it comes to two out of the
three times
you've invited me to those are two of
the three times that I've ever spoken
about the subject in public yeah it's
because you've invited me to so I don't
think it's me who's banging on about
this it's not me who's waking up every
day just desperate to see it again
every time we call you your answering
machine says if that's peers I'll do it
so don't blame me uh the class is gone
the big question have you I think we
know where this is going behind the
first one but have you proven me wrong
no yeah we convinced you is another
question the thing is read my book and
then come back to me I will read your
book but I've done a pretty good idea
what's in it because it's got Owen Jones
quoted on the front saying a crucial
riveting poleming and what Owen Jones
knows about crucial riveting polemics
can be written on a postage stamp which
has yourself which has the king of the
United Kingdom's head on it by the way
not Owen Jones's uh gentlemen and God
save him a good one nobody else is going
to in this country yeah say well there's
a lot more Royal fans than you think uh
gentlemen good to see you thank you your
campaign will fail but it will fail with
passion and I admire I bet you're a
Tanner okay
is that 10 pounds with King Charles's
picture on it yes it is